[Music]
welcome to our talk today on device
provisioning and authentication with
Android things my name is Darren I'm a
software engineer and I work on security
for Android thanks cool so I'm Wayne
Piekarski I'm a developer advocate for
Android things and IOT and so thanks for
coming today to I talk and today we're
gonna talk to you about the strategies
of getting your IOT devices connected to
the Internet to the cloud and everything
else so we're gonna go through the whole
process end-to-end and we're gonna talk
about how Google's software platforms
such as Android things firebase and
cloud IOT core help this to help to make
this much easier to do so as many of you
probably know and that's why here today
is that IOT is huge and it's gonna be
bigger than anything we've seen before
so in the same way that we saw phones
were orders of magnitude larger than pcs
I think we're gonna see IOT devices
being orders of magnitude larger than
them we're gonna be surrounded by IOT
devices on a day to day basis that do
all kinds of different tasks for us and
there's not going to be just one device
you're gonna have tens or hundreds of
them doing all kinds of interesting
things and so today we're going to give
you some hints as to ideas on how to
best build these kind of IOT devices and
how to connect them secure them and so
forth so firstly let's discuss the
basics of Android things hopefully most
of you have seen the intro talk if you
haven't we have a bunch of talks here at
i/o that cover what Android things is
but the core concept of Android things
is that it's based on a system on a
module which is shown in the image over
there which is the little small board
and so the salm contains the CPU the
Wi-Fi the memory and it's supported by
we buy what we call a board Support
Package and this provides the drivers
the kernels the libraries and everything
but it also provides updates and
security from Google and using an
Android thing some it makes it really
easy for developers to build IOT devices
and also to help ensure that they're
secure and that they're kept up to date
because those are the kind of things
that consumers need now with their
devices one other thing that makes
Android things unique is that its
support
really powerful types of processing on
device so you don't need to do things in
the cloud but you can do video and audio
processing you can do machine learning
and you could do everything on device
because we have phone level CPU
performance on these Android things
Psalms and the other thing is that it's
based on Android so you can use all of
familiar developer tools that you're
used to such as Android studio and all
the existing code that you have if
you're an Android developer and so
you'll be right at home using Android
things if you've done Android
development before so there are lots of
other talks at i/o that you can go to
learn more about that but what we're
going to focus on today is how we can
take advantage of all these things that
come with Android things to make your
IOT devices easier and better for you so
that in mind let's get into an example
that we're going to use throughout this
talk to sort of explain what we're
talking about so we're gonna build an
IOT washing machine because why not and
everyone's excited about using machine
learning and tensorflow
so therefore we probably should be using
a washing machine that does machine
learning on board it should have a
camera that looks at your laundry and
then while it's washing your clothes
it does machine learning algorithms to
analyze how clean it is and it can also
allow you to see how your laundry is
being washed when you're at work in case
you're interested in seeing this kind of
thing happen so I guess we could call
our new product tensor wash so when we
build this tensor wash washing machine
most washing machines still have a
control panel on the front because you
still want to control it manually now
because Android Things supports really
powerful devices you could actually have
like a screen on the front it could run
OpenGL you could have videos and audio
playing how so that's one option that
you could build maybe in the deluxe
model of the machine however if you want
to reduce the cost to make a cheap IOT
washing machine then you probably want
to get rid of the display and so we're
gonna leave that out for this example so
the machine is going to be IOT enabled
it's gonna have a few buttons on the
front but pretty much everything is
going to be controlled via a phone which
we're going to talk about a bit so the
real magic of a machine like this is
when it's connected to the Internet and
so you can monitor the machine remotely
you can view what the camera sees you
can trigger off a wash cycle when you
work when you're driving home whatever
so the user is not in the house and they
could be potentially anywhere in the
world so we don't want to restrict it to
just being controlled from something
that's close by in the house so we
really need to have an internet
cloud-based connection with some kind of
you know cloud solution behind that and
we can add all kinds of fun features by
having cloud support so we could have it
awarding points for you know not washing
your clothes or not wasting water too
much it could report faults to a service
department and in order to support all
this the machine needs Wi-Fi and we're
not going to cheat by just plugging in
an Ethernet cable into it so we have
this washing machine we need it to
connect to the cloud we need and we need
to share state with the clouds so that a
phone could control the device so there
are many possible cloud services we'll
talk about a few of them today but
firstly in order to make this kind of
thing work
we need to firstly get the device onto
the network and so many devices these
days these days are Wi-Fi based so the
device requires an SSID and a passphrase
to join the network many devices don't
have a keyboard or a display like in the
case of our washing machine so
everything needs to be handled by the
phone and if we use a phone then the
device needs to spin up a Wi-Fi access
point of its own the phone connects to
it
it sends all the login details over and
then the device reconnects to the
network and uses that information and if
anything goes wrong for any reason the
phone has no way of knowing what
happened and so it's a very delicate
process and so it can be problematic for
some phones or Wi-Fi networks and so
many developers find this challenging to
get right so we're gonna go through some
hints on how to make this better and and
next the device needs to know who the
owners of the device are so you want to
make sure that the device is viewed and
controlled only by the owner of the
device and anyone else that they trust
so we need some kind of authentication
token that needs to be issued by a
server that the user then uses to
control this token we put on the device
and then that's what the device uses to
contact the internet and the cloud if
the user factually resets the device
then we need to forget this token and
everything else and
the device should reset itself so that a
different user could use the Machine and
none of the previous history is
preserved so now our tensor wash is all
connected and ready to go so when the
phone device and cloud all communicate
we do that over a TLS connection such as
HTTPS so it's very important that it's
secure in that way we don't want to have
eavesdroppers in the middle the Google
services generally these days require
HTTPS and we do this and we're actually
starting to enforce this by default so
we're making it harder now for you to
use unencrypted connections because of
all the security implications and it's
important that when you build devices
like this that everyone does security
properly even tiny IOT companies that
are making really simple little toys or
whatever because everyone always thinks
that their device is not going to be the
problem and then even small problems can
have unexpected impacts in ways that you
just didn't even dream of later on once
your device is out in the wild so that's
it
that's the key concepts of what you need
to get a washing machine that we're
building and get it connecting up to the
cloud so we need to set up Wi-Fi we need
to transfer the credentials and then we
need to connect with encryption but
there's actually a lot more to it so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna let
Darren now do a deep dive on some of the
key concepts here and a bit more of a
explanation as to what's going on cool
so I want to take a step back and talk
about a few these key concepts that we
use to establish secure relationships
between devices which is fundamentally
what we're doing when we provision
devices these concepts are distinct but
they're very much intertwined in
practice as you'll see I want to talk
about authentication authorization and
at the station first authentication to
authenticate something is simply to
prove that it's genuine or valid that
it's authentic with indicate works of
art official documents handwritten
signatures we also indicate each other
mostly using face recognition this is
very natural to us it's very intuitive
computers often indicate us using
passwords automobiles often authenticate
us using keys so we use the fennec ation
all the time in our daily lives without
really even thinking about it but what
about when one computing device needs to
ascend a Kate
to another competing device this is less
intuitive for us to think about often
litter it involves is secret data so the
authentic computer has access to secret
data and all the other computers don't
and so there's two forms of this secret
data can take that I want to talk about
one its cryptographic keys and the other
is bearer tokens there are other ways to
authenticate but these are very common
and they'll directly relate to our
tensor watch example I'm you know
digging into each one of them a little
bit it's a cryptographic keys and
certificates are very common on the web
this is how your web browser would have
fennec eight a web server using HTTPS
for example I the indication involves
verifying their certificate verifying
information is difficult for fiying it
against something you already trust or
or or that you expect for fine the
authority that issued that certificate
is something that you trust we also need
to verify the proof of possession of a
key the key itself is not transferred
across a network or at least not the
private part of the key and but we need
to check that the other computer has
possession of it and it gives us a proof
of that so doing this right in practice
can be really hard building these
protocols can be really hard I strongly
recommend you don't build this yourself
find a good library that does it I if
used Android things I we have support
raids TTS and TLS built-in and so you
don't have to implement any of this so I
like to compare this kind of FN occation
to an airport passport check if you
imagine you take your passport and you
come up to the Czech I agent there is
going to validate specific information
on the passport it's it's good they're
gonna verify that it is from a Authority
that they trust and they're gonna do a
proof of possession check which in the
case of the passport is a match of the
picture with the with the face of the
person standing in front of them I also
want to talk about bearer tokens these
are a little bit work a little bit
differently they're passed from one
computer to another and in order to
verify them they're often opaque to the
computer that sends it but meaningful of
course to the computer that verifies it
authentication of the sender or bearer
of the token is implied by the
authentication of the token the verifier
looks the token and makes a decision as
to whether it sees antic token or not i
like to compare this to the example of a
movie ticket you go the ticket stand and
you buy a movie ticket that ticket
becomes your bearer token you go into
the theater you present that token
you're allowed in you pass that ticket
to your friend your friend is now the
bearer token or the bearer of that token
and they can get into the movie so often
these kinds of tokens are used to
represent a more thorough authentication
that happened in the past it's not a
good example on the web when you have a
website it requires a login you login
with the username and password and
imagine if you have to type your
password again for every page within
that site and navigate to a new page
type your password again it wouldn't be
usable and so often what happens under
the hood is a web server will issue your
browser a bearer token and and live for
a certain amount of time and it'll have
access to to your account whatever that
means on that web site and so you don't
have to keep entering your password all
the time it works the same way with an
IOT device you can authenticate it
thoroughly once the issue would have
token and you get a much lighter a much
lighter authentication mechanism from
that point forward so let's think about
authentication in the context of IOT
there's a few aspects there were aspects
that are worth calling out one is that
the authentication needs to go both ways
you need to it the services and other
devices around the device need to
authenticate that device and that device
needs to authenticate the other services
any other devices around it so for
example the device would have indicated
web service same way same way that a
browser with authenticated web service
using HTTPS or TLS also authentication
does not necessarily mean a verification
of identity often we think of it that
way but it doesn't necessarily have to
be that way take the example of a
restricted web service suppose
standard web servers but it's intended
for instances of your product to connect
back to that web service and you want to
make sure that all the clients are
actually instances of that web service
what you want to do is authenticate that
it's it's one of your devices but you
don't actually care which one and you
can actually do an anonymous
authentication in that case also we need
to bind a fennec ation to meaningful
expectations we to make sure that we're
indicating what we're thinking what
we're expecting to authenticate let me
give you a couple of examples if there's
a if there's a device in front of you
and you'd wanted you want to
authenticate that device you bind it to
something physical buying something
physical in the device if the device has
a screen you can display a code both on
your phone and on the screen for example
that's that's a physical binding of that
authentication that's a common
experience when you do like a bluetooth
pairing or something like that but you
can also use like as I sticker on the
device or a barcode and we'll talk about
that a little bit more same thing goes
with an encrypted channel if you've
established an encrypted channel and now
you need to authenticate that channel
bind your earth in ocation to that
channel so if you're using using a
standard protocol like TLS HTTP this is
already done for you you don't have to
worry about it I but if you're what if
you're doing something between two
devices for example and and they don't
support that kind of a protocol and you
need to think about this so let's go
back to our tensor watch example and
take a look at all the authentication
that needs to happen so we'll start in
the completely unproven State so we just
took our tensor washing machine out of
the box so let's assume that our smart
phones already set up our smart phone is
able to authenticate web services I
using HTTP TLS and and also in our case
let's assume that we have a Google
account we've logged in so on the phone
and so those those web services are able
to authenticate the the phone and and so
there's a two-way authenticated
relationship there the first thing we
need to do is we need to authenticate
this new device we want to do is we want
to send it credentials those credentials
to be valuable Wi-Fi passwords access to
cloud services and we want to make sure
we're sending it to the right device
before we before we send it over
and once we've provisioned that we want
to end up in this state where we have
two-way authenticated relationships
between the tensile washing machine and
cloud services so I've given two
examples here a firebase and cloud IOT
core then we're going to use with with
tensor watch and for both of these we
wanted a two-way relationship again
that's indicating Web Services will use
the standard TLS HTTPS and we'll use
those different forms which we'll talk
about one more data a little bit later
to cenek 8 the device but but those
credentials are going to be provisioned
during this process from the phone so
soon you may have noticed that there's a
110 occation that didn't go both ways in
my example what about this one here in
yellow from 10 siwash to the phone is it
ok for the tensor watch device to come
out of the box and not authenticate the
phone that's gonna set it up so we've
put it this way because it's really
common for consumer devices when they
come out of the box they're gonna
they're somewhat clean clear state they
don't have any notion of who their owner
is or who they trust they're just
they're just available to be set up as
we wanted to to build out this case and
mostly that's okay it doesn't come out
of the box with credentials that it's
going to be giving out its receiving
credentials and so it's less important
then they for example then the phone
that needs to authenticate the tensor
watch device but there are cases for
example in an enterprise zero touch
master rollout scenarios where they want
that device to come out of the box and
get itself set up it'll have to come out
of it come out of the box already with
the notion of who it who it trusts and
and this can be as simple as just taking
HTTP URL and embedding it onto the
device so when it wakes up it knows
where it can go and that can be a
registration server that can fill it in
with with the rest of the credentials or
information it needs to get configured
but we're gonna we're gonna leave that
bit out for our talking we're gonna send
we have a consumer device tensor wash
come out of the box in a in a clear
state so we've talked about
authentication which is checking whether
something's authentic and I want to talk
about authorization authorization is
checking whether something is allowed to
do what it's trying
do think back to the airport passport
check arrived at the the airport with
your with a valid passport it doesn't
mean you're gonna pass the check for
example they're gonna be checking
whether you're scheduled for a flight
that day just because your passport is
an authentic passport doesn't mean I you
you pass there's still an additional
authorization similarly with the movie
ticket scenario if you head to the
theater with a movie ticket from last
year you may not get into your movie it
has it's a different time different date
different showing and there's an
authorization that happens even though
your movie ticket is perfectly authentic
so I want to use the example of a los
2.0 which is it's a very commonly used
auto ization framework for the web it's
built for the web it may or may not work
for a given i/o to use case but it's a
good example I want to pull it a few
concepts that are important and even if
you don't use a los 2.0 you need to
think about some of these concepts the
two big ones are token scope and token
lifetime token scope is describes what
privileges are associated with the token
so what can the bearer of this token get
access to token lifetime it describes
when the token expires there's this
notion of refresh tokens versus access
tokens access tokens will be used to
access the actual resource you're trying
to get to the protected resource these
tokens are often short-lived narrowly
scoped and it can be self-contained so
the decision on the resource server is
actually pretty can be optimized and
quick and it can it doesn't need to do
any kind of backend lookups it just
looks the token that it received and it
can make a decision with the information
there refresh tokens on their hand are
used to get new access tokens when the
old access token expires these tokens
are often long-lived they're more widely
scoped so you may want to go and get
access tokens for a variety of different
scopes and they're not self-contained
specifically and what this enables is
this enables the authorization server
that's that's making the decision as to
whether it should give a new access
token based on a refresh token it can
decide if there's been a revocation of
that authorization and that's what you
want to have with IOT as well you want
to have that passive expiration so if
there is so if it's revoked
once the once the current set of access
tokens expire there's no more access
there's no way to go get another access
token you don't want to be in this
situation where you have to pull it pull
it unused IOT device out of a closet
hope it still boots up and do some kind
of factory reset in order to do is it
you want to be able to do that passively
this is a snippet from the OAuth spec
RFC 674 9 depicting the refresh token
flow you can see in the middle the
access token is used to act as a
protected resource and resource server
in steps enf there's a it's where the
access token is expired and you'll get
an error back and then down at the
bottom G and H you can see the Refresh
tokens used to go get another access
token from an authorization server
hopefully that helps you visualize it a
little bit better so let's think about
authorization in the context of IOT R of
an IOT device we talked about the Neth
indication needs to go both ways
authorization needs to go both ways as
well or at least we need to think about
it in both directions we can think about
who has access to a device who can who
can send commands to the device who can
read data from the device and so forth
we also need to think about what does
the device have access to what rights
does it have when it when it connects to
it to a web service for example we want
to use the principle of least privilege
we don't want to give more privileged
than necessary this is a really common
problem with IOT and I think it's
because it's so easy it's so easy to
just give the device a total
authorization for the service that's
connecting to because then you won't
have any more problems you won't have
any authorization errors and everything
will just work the problem is if the
device is only using 10% of that
authorization if your device gets hacked
now you're now the attacker has access
to all of it even though you weren't
using it
you also want the expiry I talked about
the passive expiration you also want to
be careful in your passing your tokens
tokens are of course made to be passed
for specific purposes verification for
example you want to make sure that
you've authenticated the recipient
before you send your token if you're
sending it up to a web service for
verification
make sure it's over HTTPS you're sending
it to if you're proposing a new device
like our tensor watch case authenticate
that new device before you send over the
token as you'll see in a few minutes I
google services like like firebase on
Android things the firebase SDK will
manage tokens for you you don't have to
worry about this token management which
is great so let's go back and look at
Auto ization in our tensor washer
scenario specifically we start in this
state where we assume the phone is
already authorized to set up new devices
with these cloud services and the phone
is implicitly authorized to set up the
tensor watch device because it doesn't
have any policies about that and where
we want to be after we provision because
we want to have a two-way authorization
with firebase so we're gonna use the
firebase real time database and it can
sync it can sink down to the device it
can also sync data from the device up to
the cloud and when it sinks down the
device we can get to use that to issue
commands to the device and so there's an
authorization where firebase is
authorized to to give commands to the
device and the device is authorized to
push data back up into firebase clad IOT
core I put the arrow in just one
direction because what we're gonna be
using it for is metrics so so as the
device is working as pushing metrics up
into the cloud IOT core project it needs
to be authorized to push into that
particular project so we're gonna show
you the details of how you set this all
up first someone talked about one more
key concept and that is at the station
attestation is really proving the
integrity of a computing device with
with state so including the the current
operating state of the device so it's
really a special kind of authentication
in order for this to be possible the
device needs to already have some kind
of a credential that it can use to prove
itself
often this is provision of the factory
so when the device comes out of the box
it can already prove that it's a it's a
genuine instance of that particular
product it's also worth mentioning that
at the station is often bound to a
cryptographic key
so instead of the the attestation
assertion from the device saying I'm I'm
a genuine device running in a secure
mode it's a bit more like this
particular cryptographic key is securely
held by a genuine device running in a
secure mode and this is useful because
it allows us to bind the attestation to
something else that uses the key some
other kind of authentication for
instance and you'll see in the example
later that we use the key like this to
connect to cloud IOT core so an Android
thing specifically I you can you can
attest various properties you can you
can test that it's an authentic Android
things device you can verify that it's
an instance of a particular product you
can verify device identity if you need
to do that you can also verify device
state like I was talking about that the
important one of them and the ones all
the ones we pull out is the verified
boot state where this device is actually
running they've proved software for that
device you can also bribe verify
attributes of the cryptographic key and
I and I won't get into that today this
is what a certificate chain looks like
five levels deep at the top we have the
Android things see a root CA an
intermediate CA these are managed by
google these are the authority for all
Android things attestation certificates
in the middle level three we have the
product specific CA and this is also
managed by Google but it's in the
context of the Android things developer
console it's associated with a
particular product on that console every
time you go and create a product on that
console there's going to be there's
going to be an intermediate level CA
that's assigned to that product so the
next level we have the device specific C
and this is provisioned to each device
in the factory this is unique for device
it contains an ID for that device and
and this is when your device comes out
of the box this is the one that it has
the last level is the application can
certificate so this was generated on the
device it's generated by by your
application
and the certificate is generated as well
by the by the device specifics CA which
is protected by the trusted execution
environment on the device so back in our
tensor wash example the attestation
happens here with the with the arrow
from the from the tensor wash device up
to the phone so when we do that
verification remember the phone was
gonna verify its gonna authenticate the
device that's what we're using at the
station so quick review we talked about
a syndication checking that something is
genuine or valid authorization checking
then it is allowed to do what it's
trying to do and at the station which is
checking the integrity of a computing
device specifically and now Wayne is
going to show us how to do all this with
Android things cool
thanks okay so now we've discussed the
key concepts so now let's talk about how
we'd build something like this using the
various pieces that are available on
Android things and from other services
that Google provides the first step is
we can use something called nearby
connections and so nearby connections is
great because it provides an abstraction
layer that helps to find nearby devices
and it establishes an encrypted
communications Channel so under the hood
it uses Bluetooth ble Wi-Fi hotspots
it uses whatever is available to it at
the time and the other nice thing about
it once the connections established is
it provides a short human readable code
on both sides that you can display on
screens now many of you have used like
devices where it shows a little code on
the screen and that's great in most
cases but we mentioned earlier that the
washing machine doesn't have a screen on
it so we don't have quite enough
security that we need and we're going to
talk about how to address that in a
minute but nearby connections is sort of
the first building block that we're
going to use and so if we look at some
code snippets this is just sort of an
abbreviated version of a nearby
connection sample you can see here that
we created nearby connections client at
the top we then specify some discovery
options we just use the default value
p2p cluster that's doesn't matter so
much what we use here and once we start
the discovery process we need to have a
service ID so in this case it's calm dot
example dot tensor wash and that is like
our products ID it's not the name of
your app on Android it's the prod
so they call it a service ID but it's
what the name of your device is or
whatever you want to call it and then we
also have an endpoint discovery callback
which nearby connections will call your
code whenever a new device is discovered
and what you would do is you'd maintain
a ListView and you would have a UI that
updates showing all of the devices that
have been discovered because only we
want to be able to support more than one
device being available at a time and
then once the user was selected the one
they want they can pick it and then we
can establish a connection on the device
side nearby supports a start advertising
method where you basically provide a
human readable name of the device and
then you put the same service ID in and
then you also set up some callbacks that
will be called whenever a connection is
established so when the user has
selected the device so they've picked it
on the screen now we need to use the
request connection method which will
handle establishing the connection to
the remote endpoint ID that's been
passed in once again there are callbacks
there and then on connection initiated
is used when the connection is starting
to that device and it fills in a content
ocation token which is that short code
we mentioned so nearby connections gives
you a short human readable value once
again we don't have a display so we'll
talk about how to do all that in a
minute
but you can see here the code is really
simple to work with nearby connections
and it gets us going quite quickly
the next thing Darren talked about
attestation and verifying the device so
we need to make sure that the device in
front of us is the one that we're
actually connecting to so what we do on
the phone is we actually create what's
called a random challenge so it's a
random number that's unique just for
this connection and then we send that
over to the device and we use this to
prevent replay attacks and the device
takes the random challenge it combines
it with the authentication code from
nearby connections brings them together
and then it uses this to generate a new
key in the Android key store with the
attestation certificate chain this
certificate chain is then sent back to
the phone and the phone can then check
it which we'll talk about in a minute
and even though we're using a random
challenge the auth code from
nearby is important because it helps to
bind it to the encryption channel that
we're using right now and another thing
is that it's also important to rate
limit failed connections so what you
don't want is for someone to be able to
constantly connect your device and try
random codes and try to get it to
generate some keys you better off rate
limiting that to prevent people
attacking your device here's some of the
code that does that don't worry about it
too much I just wanted to sort of show
you some bits and pieces of what there
is but on the device we have the
authentication token from nearby we take
in the random challenge that we got
earlier we combine it together we use
this code to generate the signing key
here and the interesting part about when
you generate something in the Android
key store is that it's done in a trusted
execution environment so we don't
actually keep the key in our app we
actually keep it in the trusted
execution environment and this is nice
because it means that even if someone
hacks in our app they don't have the
ability to pull out the private key so
that adds extra security to what we're
doing so anyway we put all this stuff in
all those purple values are all just
standard constants that you use so don't
worry about capturing this exactly later
on we're going to release a sample that
has all of this in it but I just wanted
to sort of walk you through a bit of it
but at the end you end up with you you
extract out the certificate chain and
that is what you then pass back to the
phone for it to check it and do whatever
it's going to do so Darren mentioned
earlier the concept of a certificate
chain and so the factory provision at a
station key also comes with a
certificate chain from this leaf all the
way back to the Android things root
certificate so now we have a full chain
for the key we just generated so right
on the bottom that's what we just
created and it links all the way back to
the Android things root so now a tensor
wash is generated it's custom
attestation key and certificate chain
and we've sent the chain back to the
phone so the phone needs to verify that
this is a legitimate device that's
untampered with and that it's also the
one in front of us it's actually a
pretty tedious process there's a number
of steps and it's probably something
that we should put in a library in the
future but the gist of what you need to
do is you need to verify that the
certificate chain is connected correctly
you need to verify that the root is the
trusted
from Android things you need to verify
that it's your product ID you can verify
a 128-bit use UUID for the device this
is something that at the factory you
could actually take and print on the box
with a code so that the user can verify
that they've actually matched it up
against the one in front of them you can
verify the boot status when the key is
signed it sent over with a flag
indicating if the bootloader has been
tampered with
you verify the out of station challenge
which we'll talk about in a bit and then
you end up with a public key that you
can save and it'll come in handy when we
want to authenticate with cloud IOT
later on on the phone side we need to
verify that the attestation challenge is
correct
so we extract the attestation from that
certificate and then we create a hash of
the authentication token from nearby and
the random challenge are generated
earlier and we combine them together and
we generate a hash and we check that it
matches what came from the certificate
chain from the device and this sort of
verifies that this whole loop is
complete and secure and it's important
because we never actually sent the
authentication to the device directly it
was done by nearby and so this checks
that everything's done right and that
there's no man in the middle attack
happening along the way so now we know
the device is ours and it just sort of
that helps to sort of deal with all
these issues that we've identified so
now the phone has verified it can trust
tensor wash now we need to authorize the
device on our Wi-Fi network and the
quickest way is just to pop up a
activity on your phone and say what's
the Wi-Fi SSID and password on't want to
do that it's not very user friendly and
it requires the user to enter their pass
phrase in and your app gets to see the
passphrase while it's being sent over to
the device and the next thing you do is
on the device side you then need to use
the Wi-Fi manager to set the SS ID and
passphrase so this is sort of a little
code snippet that does it however Wi-Fi
manager is a little bit more complicated
so if you look at the actual sample this
is the code you need to write to talk to
the Wi-Fi manager so this is something
that we're working on that we want to
make a small code library that you could
use that skips all this to make it so
that you don't have to write that kind
of code and we have some more good news
in that we have a new API called nearby
setup that's coming to Google Play
services and the great thing about
nearby setup which is coming soon is
that it has the ability to take the
Wi-Fi credentials stored on your phone
and pass them to another devices Google
Play services
so Android things supports Google Play
services you can copy their credentials
over without having to deal with
anything yourself the user doesn't need
to type them in and so this is great for
user convenience so this is coming soon
and the details are going to be on
developers.google.com/live I later on
when that's ready so we have internet
access on our device and we have a key
so now let's quickly talk about how
we're going to go about talking and
getting cloud services enabled on this
device so we're going to talk about
firebase and cloud IOT so the first
thing we need to do is on the phone side
we need to set up firebase firebase is
great because it works on Android iOS
and web so the phone app could be on
many kinds of devices you create a
firebase project ID and we're gonna use
that on both the phone and the device
and then we ask the phone user to
authenticate with their username and
password pop up a dialog box and we'll
get a token that we then pass down the
encrypted pipe that we created earlier
so here is a bit of a code snippet for
it you can see at the top we're doing
the sign-in request and it's interesting
because we're only requesting scope for
the email ID so we don't want to have
full Google access or access to their
files or email or any thought that we're
just asking for their identification
details because we're trying to limit
the scope like what Darren talked about
earlier we end up getting a JSON web
token that we can then pass in to sign
in with firebase which then allows our
device to interact with firebase as well
but we shipped that token we shipped the
previous token off to the device so it
can login to firebase and do things with
that so on the other side we take the
Google token pass it a firebase and
authenticate with that and the device
now has access to the faith to the face
firebase real time database the code
snippet looks very similar on the device
as well because the Android things
device is regular Android we use the
same code just like we do on a phone we
get the credential we pass it in to sign
in with credential to firebase off
and now we're done we now have a
bi-directional authorization and our
tensor wash now can fully participate
with the firebase real-time database so
let's switch gears to finish up we can
also talk to cloud IT core so imagine
you're running a laundromat with
thousands of machines in thousands of
locations and you want to do predictive
breakdown analysis so we want to push
the data from these devices to cloud 80
for analysis so in cloud IT we register
the devices you'd have an app on your
phone with some credentials and you
would take that public certificate that
we've created earlier and you would give
that to cloud IOT so that it knows the
device and that it can trust it we then
use MQTT to send request to cloud IT
with our device ID and signed with our
kii cloud IT can verify this message is
legitimate by verifying this key and
checking it with what it received
earlier so then we send the mqt request
using TLS and we use TLS so that our
device knows that it can trust who it's
sending the data to because remember
both sides need to check the other side
here's a very quick little snippet that
shows how we put in some of the project
IDs and things like that and we're gonna
be releasing the sample too soon that
shows how to do cloud IT core on Android
things and so the nice thing is that
publish device State at the bottom
basically takes any binary blobs that
you want and sends it off to cloud 80
and you don't have to worry about
generating any other messages so we
talked very quickly about cloud 80 and
firebase what are some other options of
things you can do well we also have
smart home which is our new way of
controlling devices from the Google
assistant so you can do things like if
you've got light bulbs you can say dim
the lights a little bit or in the case
of our washing machine if you implement
smart home you can do start my washing
machine and it'll kick off a load of
laundry from the Google assistant and so
by implementing firebase you write a
small web hook that plugs in a smart
home and then your device can be enabled
with the Google assistant and then
finally you can actually embed the
Google assistant SDK into your device
which means you can actually talk to the
washing machine and give it direct
commands to the machine directly which
is kind of cool so what's next we have a
factory key provisioning story coming
soon we're basically going to have a
hardware device that's
allow you to add keys onto Android
things devices something you could do
yourself or when they're being produced
and this is how this key is going to get
onto the device so if you have a
Developer Kit you won't be able to test
the key sign incorrectly because you
won't have an official key from Android
things but we're going to be releasing
the tools to be able to do this soon and
remember that nearby set up API is
coming soon as well and that's going to
be really nice to make provisioning
these things really easy
so in summary go visit our site or
Android things dot with Google comm
which is a great sort of community site
with lots of information we have a G+
community geo coyote dev where you can
find out more information and the nearby
site where you can keep track of what's
coming soon and also follow us on social
media if you haven't had a chance go get
yourself one of the imx7 developer kits
that we're giving away here at Google
i/o so make sure you get one of those so
you can try Android things out yourself
because it's a really fun development
experience it's great for meeting
prototypes but it's also great for
making production devices that's it for
us so thanks very much for coming and
we'll see you around at the conference
thank you
[Music]
you